[Music]
6 40 here on a wednesday morning we
usually have our morning cup of joe
segment with sheriff joe lombardo on
wednesdays he's running for governor as
you know so now
it's mornings with metro and today we
are joined by undersheriff christopher
darcy good to see you sir how are you
doing this morning i'm doing great thank
you for having me on the show and thank
you for being here
let's talk about one of the main issues
we've been covering recently a case ever
at a legion stadium
had his first big concert over the
weekend show went pretty well but
afterwards there was an incident
involving a couple of officers and a
suspect that
they were trying to arrest the suspect
got
his hand on one of the officers guns
opened fire i get that the officers are
going to be okay but just kind of what's
the latest on
on the case right now yes thank you so
much for asking about our officers too
it's very important we appreciate the
community support
so they're home resting obviously one
was struck by the bullet in the leg and
the other one was hit from some
splashback from the round hitting the
ground
essentially they took the suspect into
custody for pushing a security officer
they had him in handcuffs and were
escorting him into an elevator the
handcuffs were
tight or not appropriately placed so
they were readjusting them right to make
sure that the suspect was
cuffed appropriately and at that point
he was able to reach back around
stick his finger into the holster of the
firearm and a round discharge
striking the officer so with something
like that obviously we go back and we'll
do a review
whether it was equipment whether it's
training or whether it's a policy issue
well you know yesterday at the press
conference uh metro had mentioned that
this was going to be reviewed whether
it's an equipment issue or a malfunction
of some kind but
this is i believe the second time that
there's been a a case like this where a
suspect
has gotten their hand on a gun that was
the the amari nicholson suspect
terrell rhodes i believe and that was in
a different circumstance but still was
able to get a hand on the
on their gun presumably there are
traitors training and
things to try and prevent that from
happening correct would that just not
come through what happened yes that well
they're two different incidents so we'll
look at each one separately and
determine like i said whether it's a
tactical issue or an equipment issue or
a policy issue that we need to change
um in the first case you're referring to
was in an interview room with two
detectives where the gun was actually
removed from the holster and a struggle
ensued and i'm happy to say that our
officers didn't use deadly force or
anything they were able to get the
firearm away from the suspect
and in this case the gun never actually
came out of the holster
so that the round discharged while the
gun was inside the holster so the two
different
set of circumstances but it does merit
us taking a very comprehensive review
like i said on our training and our
tactics and equipment so
speaking of allegiant and the big crowds
we had in town for the fourth of july
there was a big relaunch a big
enforcement effort on the las vegas trip
downtown to try and make sure that
any sort of crime was snuffed out before
it got bad
talk about those enforcement efforts and
whether metro considers
they went well uh it did go well i mean
it was a very very busy weekend
as we look back at all the different
events that were going on the concerts
and the the event at allegiant stadium
the electric edc type festival and
everything that we had
um it was a very very busy weekend um
and i i anticipate that we could
probably continue to see that as we move
forward right
well especially when this strip started
to reopen in the first place remember
there were a lot of fights and there was
some gun violence on the strips i
imagine it's a pretty big effort by
metro to try and
make sure that doesn't come back yes and
as we've talked about before the
operation persistent pressure that we
run down to convention center area
command
really it's a partnership between all
the security of all the different
properties and all the different law
enforcement agencies in this community
really
assist us in that we couldn't do it
alone there's a lot of officers that we
need out there and i'm happy to say
that we haven't had a shooting on the
strip in three months so
our efforts are paying off we're still
retrieving
some guns from people on the strip but
not nearly as many as we were
several months ago so that continual
contact and pressure on the strip with
our partners is making a difference to
keep
las vegas safe now in addition you
mentioned partnerships there's also a
big partnership during the fourth to
track
down illegal fireworks use yes that's
not a new issue in las vegas or anywhere
else for the 4th of july
this year was a little bit different
talk about what metro did with other law
enforcement agencies and fire
departments
yes to keep an eye on those fireworks
yeah we partner with the city and the
county fire department and we go out and
i think we responded to over
650 wow we got 650 calls we responded to
about 140 of them
we impounded over 1700 pounds of
fireworks and
i mean we don't get them all right as we
know we live in the neighborhoods and we
hear them but
we made a good effort this year to try
to stop some of those fires that you had
mentioned earlier in your newscast
it's got to be hard to try and just find
them i mean it's you see them in the sky
but trying to find where they are
i mean it's got to be a needle in a
haystack it is and often when
officers go down into a neighborhood
street they run into the house or they
hide or they move they're not generally
standing outside all the time but
you know we can conduct an investigation
and determine where it came from and
issue appropriate citations right well
undersheriff christopher darcy we
appreciate you joining us this morning
here from mornings with metro
if you have a question for metro police
yourself you can submit it on our
website of course
it's eight news now dot com you can find
any for questions answered every
wednesday